[Music]
hey I have a big forehead my name is
Chris I'm somebody who really likes
things that look pretty I like it when
my food looks good I don't care about
the way food looks at all that's what
brings us here today
we want to see trendy versus traditional
which one do people prefer so when I say
trendy it could be something you want to
take a photo of it could be a trendy
ingredient or something that people line
up for outside and when I say
traditional I mean no frills
it also doesn't necessarily mean it's
based off of someone's grandma's recipe
with a book that's covered in dust it's
just simple might not look pretty but I
promise it's gonna be good decide that
we are gonna be making pancakes once
both of us are done cooking our dishes a
person is going to come in try both of
them and tell us which dish they prefer
let's make this a fair fight I'm just
trying to make sure that incas playing
with good sports all right are you gonna
wish me luck I didn't say they were old
they're traditional I barely know my own
recipe I think that's what's traditional
about it I just know what goes into it
but it's very simple I think what I'm
gonna do today is ombre pancakes is
basically a gradient of colors from
light to dark or dark to light probably
the most Instagram level stack of
pancakes I've ever seen kind of your
base level ingredients that most people
would have in their pantries this is
flour I know it looks like a Schedule
one narcotic we'll get to why there's
vinegar on the table first off we're
gonna make our pancake mix here I have
the sugar just gonna whisk the eggs in
we're not really aiming for super fluffy
cuz I want the stack to look extra nice
so you can see each layer we're gonna
finagle a little buttermilk and an easy
way to do that is you take whole milk
and you add like a teaspoon of vinegar
to that whole milk and then you let it
sit for five minutes so it curdles which
is gross but it makes the pancakes
better I want it thick
not with two seas I want to thick with
nine seas at the milk now so then we add
a little bit of vanilla I should be good
here we go we're gonna start with a big
heaping scoop of flour baking powder
some salt sugar cinnamon would be an
example of maybe some traditional
pancake recipes wouldn't call for it I
think it makes it feel a little more
reckless tea
I'm just gonna slowly add the wet
ingredients in that's good there we go
they're on the thicker side that looks
pretty good
look at this batter oh yeah now that
we've got our faux buttermilk we're just
gonna go ahead and toss an egg in there
let's add a little bit of vanilla
extract add our butter into our milk egg
vinegar God that sounds awful it's time
to make our pancake batter so let's go
ahead and just slowly whisk it in here
we don't want to over mix so we're just
gonna kind of fold hanky batter is done
now for the fun part which is to give it
some color and puree some raspberries
that looks pretty goopy I'm just taking
the seeds out the puree is ready
actually gonna try a little bit to see
kind of sour but I made the pancake mix
a little more sweet
so hopefully this hour and the sweetness
balances out I'm gonna keep this one as
it is and 43 it's gonna add a spoonful
of color for the first one ooh
okay let's do this one with two
this is what the batter looks like now I
don't actually know if after it's cooked
it's going to look exactly like this
hopefully a little darker we've let our
batter rest for a little bit now it's
time to make the pancakes butter is only
going to make the pancakes infinitely
better there's already a fair amount of
melted butter in the batter but you
can't go wrong with just a little bit
more think that's gonna help with
browning of the pancakes
you're gonna take probably like a half a
cup and just plop that boy right in the
middle
the main thing you're gonna look for are
bubbles around the top of the pancake
and that is the pancakes way of letting
you know that it's time to flip me folks
I'm gonna flip all right I'm getting oh
boy oh God
I'm gonna try and use this to see if I
can actually make the pancakes super
uniform I just think it might help a
little bit such a small pan okay I don't
know if I can keep it like this though
I'm supposed to try and make this look
pretty and I ruined it all so it looks a
bit burnt it's mainly the sides that we
need to keep that pretty color but you
can see that it's like risen a little
bit which is what I wanted the color
looks natural it's not a bright pink or
like a super like in-your-face kind of
pink but that's kind of what we were
aiming for so we're just gonna go with
this for now and let's make another one
that's this color and you're gonna see
me do this for a long time
[Music]
I'm gonna lose that looks like what we
would get in an American diner it's like
everybody's favorite
okay well that looks like something you
would get in a Michelin star restaurant
I'm flattered
now we need something to try to tell us
which one they prefer and let's bring a
dance today carries a fork and knife
with him always always I can see four
stacks of delicious homemade style Wow
pancakes
I really appreciate that butter on top
syrup for days yeah have a little look
at that one I think cinnamon the texture
was that this is something that I would
order at a diner I feel like this would
bring me back to life
this one is like something you see
hanging like in a museum you can say it
looks better it's okay all the colors
changing as you go down from light
this is surprisingly good what do you
mean a lot of the times you see things
on Instagram and I'm like not be good it
looks good but it probably doesn't taste
good this tastes good
it reminds me of like cereal like I'm a
big fan of Franken berries I taste the
hint of berries throughout in this
instance based off of look and taste
which one of these stacks looks wise I'm
gonna have to lean a little bit towards
anga side with the trendy this looks
like something I can't even afford when
it comes to overall taste and look what
I'd prefer I'm just a normal guy when it
comes down to when I'm hungry and what I
really need traditional I don't preserve
this I don't deserve this
cheers to to a pancake battle likewise I
think this is better than what I thought
it was going to be it's like delicately
berry II it's great it's really really
good we had a really great time today
and I think this can keep going I think
there should always be is trendy better
than traditional is traditional better
than trendy should you mess with a good
thing do I have something on my face
everyone if you want to see a food
trendy versus traditional let us know
what food you think we should do next
[Music]